new surveillance video appears to
capture another anti-semitic attack in
New York it's the latest in a series of
violent incidents targeting the Jewish
community the footage shows a 22 year
old Hasidic Jewish man defending himself
before a woman punched him in the neck
yesterday police took two women into
custody and one is being charged with
assault Don Dahler is in Brooklyn near
where the attack took place Don do we
know why this happened
well the motive remains unclear but the
NYPD Hate Crimes Unit is investigating
that incident and this marks at least
thirteen attacks on Jewish people in New
York City since December 23rd comes on
the heels of that horrific knifing
rampage in Muncie New York last week
that injured five people New Year's Day
offered little reprieve to New York's
embattled Jewish community as a Hasidic
man was allegedly assaulted by a 24-year
old woman on the street in Brooklyn
video appears to show the man defending
himself after one witness said the
attacker yelled anti-semitic slurs it
took him and threw him down to the
ground and broke his phone it's
unbelievable what's going on this is a
shame the incident came on the same day
that New York Governor Andrew Cuomo
visited Brooklyn in a show of support
for the Jewish community there and
directed police across the state to
increase patrols in Orthodox
neighborhoods the NYPD on Wednesday
shared surveillance video of another
anti-semitic attack in Brooklyn last
week which shows a group of people
strike a 23 year old Hasidic man over
the head with a chair and punch him in
the face police now believe the group
may also be connected to an attack on a
56 year old Hasidic man in this same
neighborhood which security cameras
captured earlier that day the violence
did not stop celebrations at Brooklyn's
Barclays center or MetLife Stadium in
New Jersey yesterday
we're tens of thousands of people
including New Jersey Governor Phil
Murphy gathered to finish a seven and a
half year study of the Talmud a vast
collection of writings which discuss and
guide Jewish law even now we have
reminded almost daily that anti-semitism
is on the rise the tale is that were joy
and our ultimate protection and this is
why we're all here today we also have an
update on one of the victims from that
Hanukah stabbing in Muncie New York the
family of 71 year-old Joseph Newman told
the Orthodox Jewish public affairs
council that if he does recover he will
likely suffer from permanent brain
damage and it could also be partially
paralyzed for the rest of his life Don
thank you
you